foreign
[Music]
we'll go over what fleets are and why
you may want to walk with fleets as you
manage your container workloads
before you continue you should be
familiar with basic kubernetes concepts
like clusters
now your cluster environment may contain
just a single kubernetes cluster
or you may choose to have multiple
clusters
there are many reasons why you may
choose to deploy multiple clusters
for example you may want to separate
staging from production environments
or you may want to have clusters in
different regions and so on
and maybe you have these clusters in
Google Cloud
or across multiple Cloud providers
on premises or a combination of all of
these
it can get pretty complex to manage
these multi-cluster deployments across
multiple environments
that's where fleets come in with fleets
you can logically group kubernetes
clusters so you can manage your
containerized workloads from a group
level instead of an individual cluster
level
for example you can apply a common set
of policies to multiple clusters at once
and ensure your kubernetes clusters and
workloads are running in a secure and
compliant manner
when you're creating a fleet the first
thing you'll want to consider is
grouping
how do you decide which clusters will be
grouped together as part of a fleet
let's take an example of an organization
with multiple lines of business if these
departments are managed separately they
may rarely communicate with each other
in this case it might make sense to have
a separate Fleet for each line of
business
how you decide to group clusters as part
of a fleet will depend on your specific
organizational needs
you'll want to consider whether the
Clusters are related to one another
if they are in the same production
environment for example then they should
be managed together in a fleet
as we mentioned earlier you also want to
consider management
clusters that are managed together
benefit the most from being grouped
together
managing your clusters with fleets helps
your organization efficiently manage
infrastructure and workloads and ensures
consistent secure operations across all
environments for more information on
fleets check out this documentation
foreign
[Music]